[Music]
let's go to michaela in
washington what's up michaela
hi dr john how are you doing i'm
fantastic how about you i'm doing great
i'm so glad to be talking with you today
i'm glad to be talking with you what's
up
well i'm calling to ask your advice hey
do me a favor do me a favor can you talk
directly into your phone
oh yes yeah there we go perfect okay so
i'm calling to ask your advice on how to
stop yelling or raising my voice my kids
and for tools on how to help my kids
learn to listen to my voice when it's
calm
instead of them waiting until i've
raised it oh that's a good question
why do you want to quit yelling
um well i was raised in a really
wonderful home but both of my parents
would resort to
to yelling okay so let me
let me reframe something
okay you were raised in an abusive
household
and there were some really fun moments
and your parents did love you
yes okay
yelling is abuse
and that's an unpopular sentiment and i
don't care
okay
so okay i want to reframe your childhood
for you
okay what you experienced as a kid was
you felt the responsibility of
regulating your parents emotional
well-being
because if you did a thing
they set off
right
yeah and so the abuse comes the trauma
comes from a child having to carry their
parents emotional well-being and
children are not that strong they're not
designed for that sort of weight
right and so okay that's what you've
done your whole life and then like most
of us you parent the way you were
parented right so tell me more right
yeah
um well i i've listened to you for a
couple years now and i i've heard you
just tell parents that you just stop if
you want to stop yelling you just stop
and it's at first i was like oh how do
you even do that and then i heard you
one time compared to like if you were to
want to stop hitting somebody you would
just stop hitting you wouldn't say i'm
trying to stop
and
that that was really um impactful to me
i don't even remember saying that but
that's pretty good i like that
well i i just it hit me because i was
like oh my goodness that i have no
excuse i just have to stop and so i
talked on your phone talking to your son
and
yeah sorry i keep moving away um i've
been working on it and i feel like it's
been really good lately i just
i don't
i don't know how to
to get my kids i've my two oldest are
pretty good about listening the first
time but the youngest are you know it's
harder for them and i just don't want to
have to resort to raising my voice
okay so i'll i'm gonna comment on one
thing you just said and then we'll
circle back
you never have to resort to raising your
voice ever true you never do
that's a choice
that is a nuclear option it's a choice i
will put one caveat
my kids running into the street and they
don't see a car coming i'm gonna scream
my head off
if i walk up on a group of kids beating
up one of my children i'm gonna get real
real real loud
okay
um
little timmy doesn't take the the trash
out and i've told him four times
i'm not yelling
i'm not gonna say all right that's
enough adult now it's time for me to act
like a child i'm not gonna do that um so
okay so circling back
here is um and i got this from james
clear i think it's just it's been a
shape-shifter for me
so i want you to start with the identity
in mind not the tactics and the goals
and the strategies okay
okay the identity is
i am a person who never yells
period
that's just who i am i don't yell
the same is like i don't like i'm just a
guy that doesn't get drunk i don't like
i just i don't like i don't i don't even
like feeling drink too i don't like it i
don't feel good i'm just that guy
i'm a guy that takes care of his body so
i like to exercise right whatever
whatever the thing is
so you are
as of today
i'm a person who never yells
and so what i have to do now that i've
established that identity is back fill
that with actions that make that
possible
okay
i am a person who never lets my kids
have control over my emotions
they're not strong enough to do that i'm
not going to give them that power
because they're kids
they don't have permission to hurt my
feelings or make me mad
i can choose and this is the language i
use in my house i am choosing to be
frustrated right now because i want my
kids to never think that they have the
strength or power to make me frustrated
i'm not going to give them that
that's good yeah okay i'm not going to
give that to my neighbors i'm not going
to give that to politicians
i'm going to choose if you say something
that's objectively offensive
or ugly or i think that's going to get
the whole country killed or something
i will say
i'm choosing to be really pissed off
right now i'm choosing anger
but not because
i'm choosing this not you
you know what i mean yeah yeah so
decide you will never never never yell
and then create a lifestyle that backs
up the identity so here's how you do
that
you find the moments when you're about
to yell
and you're gonna think it's about the
issue and it's usually not
usually it's about a period of nobody's
paying attention to me my husband
included
yeah or i'm exhausted
or
i have a set of values and y'all it's
not about
um it's not that you're not
you're not
um
taking your food off the table that's
not the issue the issue is i've been
working here on dinner for four hours
and then i made it and then i cleaned it
and you don't even have the decency to
walk that thing nine feet to the sink
you know what i mean
there's a level of injustice that rises
up and what happens is the kid who's
nine goes good god it's a plate and a
sink lady
yeah
and then you feel crazy and that makes
you even more mad
yeah and so what we want to do is we
want to identify the moments when i'm
about to yell
and it's if i want to stop eating gummy
candies i want to stop smoking weed i
want to stop grabbing an extra drink an
extra drink i'm going to look for those
moments that that push me over and i'm
going gonna be really here's the magic
i'm gonna be curious about it not
judgmental
okay
why is my body feeling like it has to
get this loud
over a knuckleheaded nine-year-old who
didn't take the trash out
why
and it might be
because that's just your your brains
defaults there because that's how you
were parented and that's how your
parents were parented and then here we
are right yeah get to the root of why
you're angry or why you're hurting
why you feel like you have to be a
volcano
yeah and all of that backs up identity
so here's how this i think i've talked
about on the show i'm not sure if i have
here's the threat i pulled from me
um
on sunday afternoons
i was unpleasant to be around i wasn't
mean i was just a
i was radioactive i was just an
energetic presence that just sent the
messages to my family y'all need to seem
to be away
i just felt it
and my wife brought that up because i
then my family would not want to be
around me and then i would overreact to
try to get like why don't you want to be
around me and then i started poking and
messing with the kids which made them
not want to be around me more and then
i'd get grumpy and then everybody so i
just cr i created a centrifuge that made
it people unable to be around me and
then i got hurt that they weren't around
me
and so my wife brought that up and i was
like oh man i don't want to be that guy
and so i started pulling the thread on
why am i grumpy on sundays i like my
work i like going to work
i don't mind i mean i'm tired because i
stay up too late on saturdays when i'm
watching the fights all the time or
going to concerts or whatever i don't
like getting up at seven o'clock to go
to church whatever but i like going to
church and i like seeing my people my
friends there so i had these different
like i like exercise so what was the
thread and when i pulled it back you
know where it started friday night
i'd get home from work after a week of
eating right and exercising and work
work work work
and then i would
murder
an entire large pizza myself
and i'd have two or three beers and i
would be all bloaty and gassed out
and all carved out of my mind and that's
not a beautiful picture i know
and
then i would sleep in an extra hour on
saturday instead of getting up and then
i wouldn't lift and then and so i
started a chain reaction on friday
that culminated in an exhausted grumpy
mutt on sunday
yeah and makes sense so
you know what really stinks i had to
quit eating pizza on friday nights
and
i had to commit to getting up early no
matter what on saturdays and going to
exercise
and that has begun to shape-shift my
sunday afternoons
okay
so i tell you that i was a journey of
curiosity
what about this and well what about that
and maybe it's because it right but all
of it was a backfill of i am a guy that
my kids want to be around on sundays
yeah i want to be a joy to be around
and yeah me too everything works better
right so
can we commit will you commit together
yes
i will never yell i will never give my
kids
the power to affect me emotionally like
that
yeah
yeah i want to do that i'm no no no no
no no i'm going to do that there we go
i'm going to
yes you can
well and that helps having that um like
you said to pull that thread because i
think that's probably where most of it
comes from is my own frustrations with
who knows what but not but being out of
touch with that
and something just sparks it you know
and
can i tell you what
i'm not listening a common one
with young children is a sense of
powerlessness
and a sense of if they're not doing what
i say
it is representative that i'm failing as
a parent and if you're a stay-at-home
parent that's my only job and i'm
failing at my job they are my walking
scorecard and i'm failing
i want to free you from that that's not
the case nine-year-olds do nine-year-old
stuff
yeah okay
one thing you've heard me say this a
million times i'll and i'll keep saying
it it would really be helpful
if you created a set of family values
one of them is i don't yell you need to
get in front of your kids and say i've
been handling this wrong and i'm sorry
i'm going to make some changes in my
life
and when i do yell y'all call me out on
it
yeah oh yeah that's good sit down and
tell me listen we're going to make a
series of family values i'm going to
hang it on the wall this is who we are
and listen when they don't take the
trash out
you call them in and say it breaks my
heart that you chose to fill in the
blank um consequence
i hate that you chose to not go fishing
this weekend i hate that because you
love fishing i love taking you fishing
and you chose not to by not doing that
yeah they own the choice i don't have to
yell they're owning the consequence but
mama dude
you chose that that's a strange choice
fishing's way more fun than
i mean it's it's it's five hours of fun
versus eight seconds of taking the trash
out but that's what you chose it's
strange but you see what i'm saying i'm
holding that so loosely there's no
reason to yell none none none
yeah
yeah i know that's that's good
the choosing i
think i've been using on my
five-year-old i heard you mentioned that
before and i've been like you know
when she's having those heart is like
you're choosing this consequence right
now because you're not you have been
using those words but i don't use them
on myself and yeah
so let me hold the mirror up
you are choosing to yell
yeah
don't make that choice you're choosing
to do things upstream or experience
things upstream or to not have hard
conversations with your husband or your
extended family or whatever these
challenges are coming up river you're
choosing to not and you're taking it out
on your kids at the bottom of the creek
and so hear me say this as sternly as i
can yelling is trauma
don't okay
yeah i believe that you're committed to
not
i am
cool yes because i know that yes
absolutely
take back control of the emotional
regulation and make that an adult thing
not a kid thing cool
okay cool hey sounds good you're here's
what you're doing i don't want you to
miss this
you are changing your family tree
you are healing family trauma and
creating a new family legacy this is
hard you'll stumble at it you'll mess up
and you're going to come away with scars
and it's exhausting and it's frustrating
and it's worth every minute
because you're going to have grandkids
that you have not met yet they're going
to have parents that handle their
idiotic eight-year-oldness differently
because of the work you did
you're changing family trees and i'm
proud of you and it's hard
and you can do it